[Music]
and unconventional method news submitted
by two in the stink
yo several prisons have painted their
jail cells pink as a way to curb
aggressive behavior oh I've heard of
that I think one of the state prisons in
Arizona all the jumpsuits are pink one
in Texas um but this one they're talking
about several Swiss prisons that they
have painted their jail cells a color
called cool down pink and this is based
off of some research that happened a
while back saying that in the 70s saying
that the power of color really it really
affects you thank you
yeah there's looks like ecology behind
colors for sure it really affects your
behavior your human behavior they say
that pink lowers amount of testosterone
induced men especially the pepto-bismol
kind of pain I feel like I'm in a donut
shop or some ice cream shop yeah I feel
like we should all come out wearing like
cute little dresses and aprons but they
do have pink jumpsuit that's cute it
might make them too horny right what
lowers the testosterone it feels like an
Instagram [ __ ] stars like place to
take a photo shoot yeah they're like
Melrose I feel like it'd be hard to get
in a fight in a place like that yeah
well I mean if you imagine being stabbed
in a place like that yeah Webb Anderson
movie Oh like where there's like blood
gets splattered but it's on a pink wall
and it's not like white angolan just
gotta be a bunch of picture frame
Chandler but yeah they're saying that
this is the so back in the 70 that's
when they had this more brighter pink
and they were calling it Baker Miller
pink and that was the go-to
anti-aggression pink until they've
decided to conduct more color
experiments on inmates and this time
they found the calming pink the
pepto-bismol pink it's so interesting
yeah the first pink was a hot pink so
they were all hot tempered I just think
of the Homer Simpson donut oh yeah I
wear different colors every day and
today as a pink day oh yeah you're a
hard time on your watch - yeah
binkey you know what you tell me about
your color days I thought it would be
like the full thing oh yeah no I mean it
can be but sometimes I don't have a lot
of pink full what's the signs behind
that I was like numerology and like
certain colors like based on your
numerology like help you during the day
for me it's just like it's easy easy way
to pick an outfit or accessorize or
whatever and then it also is like a
little reminder for the day so it's like
each color has a different meaning so
pink is success so it's just like a
feel-good type of success daily you're
gonna be successful - they're succeeding
and then yeah
succeeding yeah and then um then
tomorrow's pastels which is like a
letting go it's like a letting good vibe
I mean it can be any color just as long
as yeah as long as it's pastel and could
be a mixture of different pastels and
stuff but it just reminds you like oh
what am I gonna let go of today you know
like you're constantly working next day
yeah well that's good you take a shower
mind fine shower right Shh you wash it
out and you're like yeah fresh yeah all
the negativity can't release it so and
then the next day is a red day which is
a number one New Beginnings day so it's
like now you're starting fresh after
releasing all of that number nine and
you have like a calendar based on your
emotions or like it's this thing based
off of your birthday oh yeah it's a book
called people always ask you about this
but it's a book called colors and
numbers by Louise Hay and she tells you
how to break down everything it's really
easy and people like how do you do math
everyday but it really is just goes in
order so I don't do math every day it
just goes in order and so many colors
Erlik 909 mm mm you just rotate them
every time yeah I mean so one is red two
is orange three is yellow four is green
and each has like a different like
meaning for nine it takes the thinking
out of like that [ __ ] gets overwhelming
yeah that's one of the main reasons why
I don't even want to think about that
shouldn't go out I'm just like damn I
can't wear my shorts I mean you can't
wear other colors cuz I notice you're
wearing like black no you could wear
other colors yeah I mean you can wear
whatever you want gonna like hurt you if
you wear a different color but I just
like to have a reminder of that color
every day and if I had it that's
positive or whatever then I would wear a
pink shirt but I don't really have a lot
of pink I don't have a lot of purple and
I don't have a lot of pink but I have a
lot of red and I have a lot of orange in
black and white
it's cool to have like a daily reminder
to be positive in a different way and
like green is a responsibility day so
like like remember to pay all your bills
you know go through your finances
organize all that stuff it's more oh
that's good man
shoot the shoot the chart okay I only
have to have it on the system or else I
get all scattered all over the place
shoot the [ __ ] I'm gonna [ __ ] this up
shoot this Shh artichoke give us the
chart I will you take your well um I
tell you right now yeah I'll just get a
send it to you I'll send you a
spreadsheet Oh should I get a
spreadsheet [ __ ] you okay add up your
birthday numbers that's it 1112 suggest
the month and day not the years I think
I know my number I know mine like nine
so his name wait I need I didn't
calculate I'm stupid okay um see narrow
it down till I get send it to one number
I know but she's gonna tell us more so
13 narrows down to four cuz then you do
three plus one yeah you've never all the
way done what do you mean narrowing it
and add it up so you go 1129 is your
birthday right
so one plus one from 11 is 2 and then 2
plus 9 is 11 over here and then 2 plus
11 is 13 - you want my calculator 1 plus
3 because the 13 you know the 1 plus 3
that's 4
so your four you have to keep I'm afford
to or two so you're all paper all pink
things you have to keep going until it
seems well did you not JK we're pink all
of my nails you have to keep going until
it's a single digit number yeah keep
going
yeah 7 it's more 5 6 7 ok yeah
so you're 7 oh you start wearing colors
too with pink you add your it's not I
picked it for you Oh what is it oh you
have to add that to the universal year
which is 2019 so 2 plus 1 plus 9 Wow
that's 12 this was a three year for
everybody I already lost one four plus
three yeah pork with sweet for us and
then seven plus three for Joe which ends
up being 10 which is it being one so
it's a one year for you that's new
beginnings that's red it's a red year
for you I have one red t-shirt all right
so the red day a seven year is
transformation it's a transformative
year oh my god
which reminds me
sorry I got excited but yesterday I took
a spirit animal quiz I love the
direction this way your bird / purple
it's it's like you know butterflies I
guess butterflies yeah quiz but why
would I mean she wanders all over the
place no caterpillars turn into a
butterfly formation and like by me cuz
you know that's why I just like reminded
me about that and I got excited um but
then it also means like that I guess in
my personality I tend to be playful and
very light which I don't know about that
but it ends up being on the light part
yeah cuz you heavy sometimes I feel
pretty skinny though yeah maybe you're
just in your cocoon that cocoon is heavy
girl you're gonna break out of it you
know what I have been feeling my playful
side come out more like my old self I
noticed it too
yeah it's like last night it's really
funny in Austin Casey oh my god you
turned off the lights again anyway
no but after I got out of the shower I
put like my towel on and I was playing
music and then I felt like my teenage
self again where I started like dancing
to the music I was air drying my hair
and I'll just like last time how's it go
thought I forgot a part of me like this
side of get up the kid part of you like
your inner child yeah I lost her for a
minute yeah where did she go she flew
away like a butterfly oh yeah so then
you're saying that so it's a number 7
year for all of us us 3 and then that's
for transformation here and then so the
month you would add like the 7 to the
month which is August which is an era no
is it August yeah so it's a 8 month plus
a 7 so that's 15 so it's a 6 month which
is an adjustment month
it's a navy-blue month and then next
month is gonna be a triple 7 for us
because that's it's the 7 month and then
it's in a 7 year so it's the most
transformative month of the whole year
next month Saturday three I mean
Saturday whatever is the most remembers
the most transformative month for us
because it's it's a seven month and it's
in a seven year and it's the most like
whatever your year is solely for you
it's new beginnings so seven
I mean September would be the most new
beginnings month for you like your
that's always awesome like double power
in it I'm gonna have a new beginning
yeah I always like beginnings never
endings yeah I just keep always
resetting well this month is an endings
month for you oh oh [ __ ] it's a letting
go letting go number nine months and I
like to go to the bathroom a lot
mmm that's good ended up but we just
remind everyone gel sale we're still
kind of talking about colors yeah yeah
that's true but I guess the gesso so
anyway so then more about this article
is that the prisoners feel that it's
very degrading oh maybe in a pig's and
manhood yeah is that what it is because
they're like oh we're nut girl if they
were secure in their sexuality felt like
it was a little girls bedroom but they
don't even have rights though yeah maybe
so because they can't vote they don't
know their millennial criminals dude and
I can't feel hard when I'm in this room
even the criminals these days are just
like I don't know this I can't shape to
this color yeah but that's a point
they're being successful with it wait so
are they Kenny are they getting their
voices heard well so that's what they're
saying that others are claiming that the
association of color with femininity
femininity femininity yes that minion
yeah femininity maybe and weakness is
stereotypical discriminatory and sexist
so they're sexist criminals when you're
sheltered yeah so and they're saying
that there was this one gender studies
scholar who called the practice of
keeping inmates and pink prison cells
humility humiliating and degrees Oh one
gender studies scholar one Oh suck it
yeah i'ma go with whatever psychology
says if this isn't a lower aggression
I'm before that yeah
they did say that it did I can't be hard
in these clothes man that's the point
Oh mmm we want you to not be hard yeah
exactly
well wonder how that would work here in
like the LA prisons that'd be cute oh
it's like all over the place
oh I wish you'd talk about Swiss prisons
in particular I want to see them do like
group dance like the Filipino prison
they do a good job what do they do they
do like Flashdance kind of it looks good
really like choreograph like don't do
thriller and all kinds of stuff it's
really like you too it gives them a
purpose I'm going to do you're not like
unity like a team and a creative outlet
people need that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]